nous continuons cette édition du 7 8 à
présent avec trois nouvelles invités
autour de ce plateau parce qu'elle
heurteint bonsoir à vous Elsa duno View
et Tatiana Bosc bonsoir à toutes les
deux on va parler de poésie plus
précisément d'une opération que vous
allez mener avec le club jeune de
voisins bretonneuse club jeune activité
théâtre poétique que vous proposez
premier juin 21h base de loisirs
parcours dans les arbres ça c'est le
lieu du rendez-vous et comment ça va se
dérouler une rencontre poésie sur le
thème les arbres prennent des couleurs
en fait ce sont les jeunes lycéens de
notre club qui vont
déclamer des poésies dans les armes donc
en fait ils vont monter eux dans le
parcours de
dans les armes en fait et quand ils
seront sur les plateformes en hauteur
ils vont déclamer chacun leur tour les
poésies donc le nom de l'opération les
arbres prennent des couleurs c'est
pourquoi les poésies sont sur le thème
de la couleur en fait chaque poésie a
des couleurs et c'est pour ça ce sont
des auteurs différents il y aura Boris
Vian et plein d'autres auteurs
différents et vraiment le thème ça veut
pas dire un auteur seulement mais
plusieurs poésies de chaque auteur qui
se chargera de lire ces différents
poèmes les jeunes lycéens justement du
club en fait ils sont 13 c'est ça si
j'ai bien suivi de la seconde à la
terminale et il participe ils se sont
impliqués dans dans l'association depuis
quand comment ils sont arrivés pour
beaucoup ils ont commencé théâtre il y a
déjà quelques années
on a quelques débutants mais c'est
essentiellement des jeunes de qui ont
déjà trois quatre ans de théâtre plus
derrière d'accord vous avez commencé
quand justement au théâtre
6 ans 16 ans 16 ans le record est pour
vous 6 angles comment commence le
théâtre à 6 ans alors on commence avec
des toutes petites scénettes vraiment
des petits jeux au départ c'est plutôt
de l'éveil et on apprend pas de texte
parce que vraiment à 6 ans c'est ou
alors de très courte phrase et voilà au
fil des années ça s'étoffe ça s'étoffe
et puis on arrive à créer une vraie
troupe grâce à cette
je trouve que voilà j'ai pas arrêté
depuis parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui apporte
pour l'instant ça reste un loisir pour
chacune d'entre vous ça reste un loisir
donc cette opération en premier juin 21h
base de loisirs c'est ouvert à tous tout
le monde peut y accéder voilà c'est pour
ceux qui souhaiteraient s'y rendre à la
base de loisirs c'est en partenariat
avec la maison de la poésie aussi des
opérations que vous menez comment c'est
accueilli par la Maison de la poésie
c'est les initiatives justement d'une
association jeune club Jeune Théâtre de
voir que justement il y a une relève et
que c'est pas une seulement une
discipline pratiquée entre personnes
retraitées par exemple très provoquer un
petit peu le directeur de la Maison de
la poésie qui nous regarde sans doute
très bien parce que en fait
l'implication des jeunes aujourd'hui est
très importante et du coup le fait que
les jeunes se lancent là-dedans se
lancent dans la poésie ça montre une
envie tout simplement de perdurer ce que
nos parents ou nos grands-parents comme
Michel qui est le pilier du club gtaâtre
nous donne des valeurs et ça perdure ces
valeurs là parce que c'est vrai aussi
qu'un projet comme ça qui allie à chaque
fois
euh la poésie donc un aspect aussi du
théâtre la musique parce qu'il y a un
musicien qui va venir nous accompagner
pendant cette manifestation et en même
temps un peu l'aventure et le côté jeune
qui est le fait de monter dans les
arbres grâce au parcours de la base de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin ça plaît aussi
aux jeunes c'est vrai que c'est pas
juste réciter une poésie
ça fait plusieurs années qu'on travaille
avec la Maison de la poésie et ce projet
là les a vraiment
trois projets qui sont menés parce qu'il
y a aussi des projets à destination des
collégiens par exemple peut-être en
parler oui bah justement
dans le reportage précédent on a vu
quelques jeunes du groupe du mercredi
des collégiennes qui sont allés dire des
poésies de l'auteur gagnante du prix
positive
et donc voilà et puis un autre projet de
poésie avec les autres grands mais
Tatiana on parlera mieux que moi que
c'est son groupe qui voilà avec les
autres grands c'était un projet de
poésie qui se déroulait à la Maison de
la Poésie donc il est habillé en cours
et du coup c'était de reprendre donc un
recueil de textes et de mettre en scène
donc ça c'est fait avec avec des ballons
avec beaucoup beaucoup une mise en scène
très poétique je dirais voilà avec une
approche moderne malgré tout très jeune
de toutes ces problèmes le but de cette
association initié former les jeunes
donc dès l'âge de 8 ans développer des
partenariats culturels aussi comme on se
porte l'association comme un sport de
vos activités très bien ce qu'on a de
plus en plus d'enfants qui est
d'adolescents qui veulent participer qui
veulent s'inscrire au club au fil des
années donc ça a vraiment un impact
sur voisin mais aussi la communauté
d'agglomération aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
on a 70 enfants adhérents 70 enfants
adhérents et ceux qui veulent
éventuellement découvrir vos activités
il y aura le premier juin 21h à la base
de loisirs ce rendez-vous les arbres
prennent des couleurs et ensuite il y a
d'autres rendez-vous avant les vacances
ou il faudra s'installer pour la rentrée
il y a un festival
donc du club Jeune Théâtre du vendredi
14 juin au dimanche 16 juin donc avec
tous les spectacles qu'on a préparé
cette année dans différents groupes donc
là c'est le spectacle de théâtre voilà
ça serait exclusivement du théâtre mais
donc voilà si les gens également s'y
rendre à toutes les trois et puis bien
sûr vous pourrez vous inscrire à la
rentrée si vous souhaitez vous inscrire
inscrire aux enfants merci donc à vous
ne pas oublier des mails et après
inscription et à Michel voilà
compris vous êtes nombreux à vouloir y
participer merci à vous